it's incredibly important to innovate
around mental health because we've seen
that standard Solutions just aren't
working
people can't afford it it's super hard
to find a therapist of color if you're
looking for one or someone that
identifies with your cultural background
and so we need more players in the
mental health space that are really
really committed to providing care that
meets people where they are
thank you
mind ride is a mental health startup
based here in Newark New Jersey and our
whole mission is around advancing Health
Equity by making Mental Health Care
radically accessible and inclusive
I've always been entrepreneurial and I
think it runs in the family I probably
get it from my dad he grew up here in
Newark and the city is just full of the
spirit of hustle and getting stuff done
you know I always knew I wanted to start
my own company so growing up Stanford
would really be the dream just given all
the resources that there are and I knew
if I was surrounded in that environment
I could really make something happen the
question was what
I worked here in education at a Charter
High School not far from where we are
right now and just fell in love with
that experience and working with my
students who are the most incredible
strongest people I know
but I also saw the trauma they
experienced and mental health challenges
that were often unmet because no young
person wants to talk to a therapist it's
not cool there's a bunch of stigma and
if you actually are interested you can't
afford it maybe you don't have
transportation to get there and so after
seeing my students kind of face these
challenges I just thought how can we
make mental health like one more
accessible and then two actually fun for
a teenager to do
to keep it simple mind right is coaching
over text message it's not an app
nothing you have to download on your
phone it's just straight texting to keep
it as simple as possible and accessible
as possible so to sign up you just text
us then you get matched with your
personal team of coaches and every day
they are proactively texting you like
hey Ashley how's your day going how'd
your basketball game go yesterday how's
it going applying to colleges Etc and
the best part is you're talking to the
same people every day so it's not like a
traditional mental health hotline where
you're getting a different person that
you don't know at mind's right you
really get to build a relationship with
the people who are supporting you and we
have people who have been texting mind
right for you know three to four years
at this point
the second part of what makes us
different is that we recognize that it's
not only important to be there for you
when you're going through a tough moment
but there's so many young people when
something good actually happens in their
lives they don't have someone who can
actually celebrate them or who is there
to help Express positivity and we've
been told by our members that that is as
important as having support when you're
going through the hard times
being at the GSB you just feel like
everything's possible and I had a bunch
of Dreams before I got there but to be
in a place like Stanford where you
actually are surrounded by people and
resources that are committed to help you
succeed it's amazing I don't think if I
was anywhere else I would have had that
immediate support to be able to launch
mind right eventually into what it is
today
it really just expands how you think
about the world and problems and
solutions so when it came to mental
health and just thinking about creating
a solution that could better serve my
students what I realized and what I
strongly believe in is that healing can
look different for everyone and for some
people that is clinical therapy and for
other people that can be mine right I am
doing work that I feel like I am truly
changing lives we are providing daily
mental health support to youth who
otherwise may not have access young
people who have suicidality who have
thoughts of self-harm I feel like they
have no one to go to but are able to get
support from mind right I think all of
our coaches and our clinicians on our
team are helping us change lives and by
changing lives you ultimately change the
world which I think is what's happened
when you have a community of people that
are actually healed and are actually
well and that's really what mind writes
about
my name is Ashley Edwards and I am the
founder and CEO of mind right health
[Music]